after his time with Transformers
LaBeouf's controversial reputation would
only grow and grow in February 2013 a
Broadway production of the play orphans
was canceled after he reportedly quit
over what was later revealed to be a
fight between him and his co-star Alec
Baldwin that fight gave fire to the
rumors that LE buff also got into an
altercation with Tom Hardy on the set of
the 2012 film Lawless a year prior but
as Le buff claimed during an appearance
on the YouTube talk show hot ones there
was nothing to that story Beyond some
playful wrestling I respect him as an
actor he has a different appetite for
you know being a method actor than I do
then in 2014 Le buff was arrested after
causing a scene at a Broadway production
of Cabaret this was just the beginning
of a string of arrests for disorderly
conduct as he again faced charges in
2015 and 2017. the latter of those
arrests was a self-admitted new low for
Le buff as he was caught on camera
accusing a black police officer of
arresting him for being white and that
wasn't the end of his run-ins with the
law as he was charged with misdemeanor
battery and petty theft in 2020.